that Lila the Christ nor the humility to
lose a commanding we go high
okay you can do this you are a confident
woman who can deal with conflict I'm
gonna pass
scowler tell them your decision they're
rational
they may even become frogs
probably just a chance
you thought that I was rude you were
sitting with me I was mesmerized by your
beauty
they were always want to be you he came
as fast a food there's been a terrible
accident
Aleksey son has been hit by a train
exclaiming his son was partners and
should you realize murder is strictly a
capitalist disease just to be quiet
there is no murder in this country there
is no matter do you understand
I won't be back to the match I'll uh
I'll laughter listen to it on the radio
dad you said you've embarked he's
rubbish on the radio is your brother
there
yeah Jonah was know uh just till you
just tell your mother to call me when
she gets back thinking thank you yeah
sure I love you what uh okay you know
what just just get her to call me what
yes yeah
thank you all right hi
in this wasteland I am the one who runs
from both the living and the dead who'd
used to a single instinct survive you
get $10,000 come on
unless you want the dog you give me 10
simple you listen about you can't come
walking into people's lives and expect
my son please take it easy listen to me
that is life
that's what it is people like me coming
along where you're gonna look in
I gotta watch you die all over again
what you're talking about I gotta find
you lying in a pool of your own blood
drag your damn body to my car drive you
down to the hospital your throat cut
from ear to ear you do that I'm not
doing it again I thought I want and I
just like you to believe your own damn
legend my boys the negativity start is
even worse than imagine this helps us
have already issues are more powerful to
catharsis are you gonna reconcile them
for so strength I'm working on that on a
facet projections are closing and quick
we gotta break out of here over 200
Foxton
mustn't be afraid to dream a little
bigger darling
I'm Gotham's reckoning huh
Nancy just tell me your punishment must
be more severe
you did a stumble back
I don't know